I love making interesting videos the
most interesting topics are often
exceptions deviations from the norm all
of us live in countries where there are
laws and rules and governing bodies
telling us what we can and can't do but
70% of the world is ocean where there
are no countries no governing bodies to
tell us what's right and wrong
that's why maritime law exists let's
start with a hypothetical a baby is born
on a cruise ship sailing in the middle
of the Atlantic Ocean
what nationality does it take this is
the coast of some fictional place in
some fictional country governed by some
fictional government from this line
which is the water line at the lowest
low tide every country is allowed 12
miles of territorial waters it used to
be three miles the distance a cannon
could shoot off shore but that has since
changed those twelve miles are the
property of a country they can do pretty
much whatever they please in it and all
domestic laws apply foreign ships are
however sometimes allowed to enter into
these waters under the principle of
innocent passage if ships have an
innocent purpose which does not include
fishing polluting weapons practice or
spying they are allowed to pass through
the territorial waters of a foreign
nation without permission as long as
they do so quickly and without stopping
on shore beyond the territorial waters
there's another 12 miles of the
contiguous zone this zone allows a
country to enforce laws as long as they
fall into one of four categories if the
laws have to do with customs taxation
immigration or pollution they can be
enforced in the contiguous zone beyond
the contiguous waters is the exclusive
economic zone also known as the EEZ this
zone extends 200 nautical miles from
shore beyond the territorial waters the
EEZ is in international waters however
only the country who holds the exclusive
economic zone has the right to harvest
natural resources in the area this law
was originally set up to help with
disputes over fishing rights but has
since been incredibly useful with the
boom in oil drilling all these laws do
however occasionally cause some disputes
due to overlapping zones this is the
South China Sea an incredibly important
waterway nearly one third of the world's
shipping traffic passes through it and
it reportedly has huge untapped oil
reserves China has this Lane
so it says it has all this water
Malaysia has this land so it says it has
all this water Vietnam has this land so
it says it has all this water Brunei has
this land so it says it has all this
water the Philippines has this land so
it says it has all this water when two
countries are less than 400 nautical
miles away from each other it's up to
them to decide where their respective
economic zones end most solve it civilly
by separating the zones at the
equidistant point from each of their
Shores
however when the stakes are so high such
as in the South China Sea countries can
be a bit less cordial
so our cruise ship baby let's change the
hypothetical and say that the cruise
ship was sailing in us territorial
waters less than 12 miles away from
shore every ocean-going vessel is
required to be registered in some
country you'll notice that most large
cruise ships are registered in tiny
faraway countries Panama a nation with
fewer people than Minneapolis holds the
registration of one quarter of the world
ships because taxes and labor are low
when a ship is in international waters
the laws of the country of registration
apply a ship registered in Amsterdam
could legally have prostitution and
marijuana on board as long as they got
rid of the drugs and shut down the
brothels before sailing into territorial
waters whence a ship is in the
territorial waters of a country the on
board law switched to that of the
country the ship is physically in this
is the same for nationality law kinda a
baby born on a Dutch ship within 12
miles of the US is a baby born in
America since the u.s. is one of the
thirty countries that unconditionally
grant citizenship to any baby born
within the country a baby born in u.s.
territorial waters is lucky enough to
receive the world to eighth most
powerful Passport there are two
exceptions to this rule foreign
diplomats visiting or living in the US
with a diplomatic passport are not
subject to the laws of the US or any
other nation other than their own
consequentially the babies of foreign
diplomats do not automatically receive
American citizenship additionally the
babies of individuals staging a hostile
invasion or occupation of American
territory are not granted American
citizenship upon birth here's where
things get even more confusing even
though a ship in international waters is
an extension of the territory of the
nation it's registered in law lies the
for nationality are different the United
Nations treaty on the reduction of
statelessness which is followed by some
countries says that a baby born in
international water should just take the
nationality of their parents most of the
world's countries use this principle of
bloodline to determine if a baby should
get citizenship rather than whether or
not a baby was born in the country
however there are some countries that
won't give citizenship to a baby born
outside the country in that case the
baby would take the citizenship of the
country in which the ship was registered
all right that's enough with babies
there's a long history of exploiting
maritime laws during Prohibition US
ships started to change their
registration to Panama and other foreign
countries so they could serve alcohol in
international waters in the mid-century
Casino boats left from many cities where
gambling was illegal to partake in legal
gambling in international waters in 2005
entrepreneur Rodger green started c-code
a company that planned to evade US labor
laws by placing an old cruise ship 12
miles off the coast of California they
would bring in foreign coders and house
them in this ship where they would not
have to abide by US wage laws or go
through the difficult visa application
process the idea never came to fruition
but the technical legality of it just
shows how convoluted maritime law is the
laws for airplanes are pretty much the
same technically once an airplane has
taken off the laws of the country of
registration apply the only law that
applies and differs among countries is a
drinking age a British Airways flight
from New York to London can serve
alcohol to 18 year olds however in most
cases airlines choose to follow the laws
of the origin country spacecraft also
follow very similar laws and luckily I
have a whole other video just about
space law make sure to check it out here
you can also click here to subscribe to
Wendover productions and follow me on
twitter at Wendover pro please also be
sure to check out my last video on why
college is so expensive it's a great
video so please check it out if you
haven't done so already thank you for
watching and I'll see you soon with
another one over productions video